you
let's consider water not carbonated
water a toilet water but just plain
everyday water h2o you probably never
gave it a second thought it used to be
when you wanted a drink of water you
just took it but now thou shalt not
drink water from any other source than
that designated else now become victim
to an unhappy fate more painful and
Japanese led thou shalt use thy water
sparingly and wisely else thy days and
my brother's days shall be numbered so
brother in a combat area get you water
from A lister bag it may not taste like
no water from that old oaken bucket but
it is pure and healthful use it wisely
you're on a march under a blistering hot
Sun even that chlorine taste good so
good that some jerks want to down at all
at once like like our old friend
McGillicuddy kind of hot ain't it Mack
oh why don't you take a little drink
here we go hmm see what I mean what a
jerk for two months we've been begging
him to take a bath and now he doesn't
the great McGillicuddy full of them and
full of water an empty canteen and an
empty head now let's see how far he gets
oh beginning to drag it a
now it's really getting hot hotter than
it was before oh Mack oh your tongues
dry isn't it Mac you know what y'all to
have you ought to have a nice drink of
water why don't you look in your canteen
you started out with plenty of water
there it is Mac water get it Mac oh
that's a dirty lowdown shame water love
it all right Mac don't get dramatic
after all you're only a couple of miles
from camp water
come back back go back listen
knucklehead you can't drink that water
it hasn't been inspected it might even
be poison yet they ever be in your gums
now how do you feel about drinking that
water not so good huh well let's take a
look upstream and see what gives that
stuff its kick CMAC here's you here's
the gorilla a few dead Japs some pigs
in a native village what's wrong with
the native village very pretty very
pretty but do you know what that is that
McGillicuddy is a headhunters head
direct from the manufacturer to the
consumer a prize in every bag brother
you at the jackpot
monotonous isn't death McGillicuddy